I am crossing a line but I don't know I
just can't it just frustrates me so much
that I can't keep my mouth shut that's
hot of her Janelle's cool as hell
sister wife star Gwendolyn Brown is all
for Janelle's confidence I definitely am
for that the daughter of Cody and
Christine praises the mom of six and her
second YouTube reaction video of the TLC
series why for standing up for her
sister Isabelle going back to school
during the coveted pandemic despite Cody
wanting her to stay at home you know
what I wonder though Cody when are you
feeling like you could have a normal
life again what point is that point I
love her getting confident I am crossing
a line but I don't know I just can't it
just frustrates me so much that I can't
keep my mouth shut that's hot of her
Janelle's cool as hell everything went
upside down right like every family
culture got challenged our worlds went
upside down we all had to stay home I
think there was a lot of challenges and
it played out in
in just as complicated way in our family
as it does in the bigger sphere but
Janelle's not the only one getting props
from Gwen she also gives kudos to her
mama Christine for how she handled the
end of her relationship with Cody whom
she left in 2021. I wonder how they had
to like go through it or if it was just
like moreover it was kind of like a
breakup and I'm also going to be moving
to Utah my mom was honestly such a good
woman she probably could have taken him
for like all he's worth and like robbed
him blind but but she really didn't she
left that pretty impressively as far as
just planning in day-to-day life and I
really just feel like this is the path
I'm supposed to be on now
so we know Christine and Janelle both
called it quits with Cody and during the
Sister Wives one-on-one special it was
revealed Mary did the same he says no I
don't consider myself married to Mary
like he just made the decision yeah and
that leaves Cody down to one wife Robin
the only one he's legally married to
you've got to be able to to manage these
things but it seems Cody's former wives
are all moving forward in a positive way
for Janelle she's prioritizing her
health this year
only coming back to life
as the years progress
there's more and more to it for me so I
find real value in it and Christine well
she's happy now living in Utah check out
her new set for next season of Sister
Wives so you can see behind me this is
where I sit
and it's like Way Forward like this is
where I sit the producer sits in this
lovely desk that he made behind me it's
my basement it's unfinished it's super
awesome it's like my favorite room in
the house is the basement that you'd
like a little bit of a sneak peek mwah
doing really really well love and love
and living in Utah close to my kids it's
been Fabulous As for Mary she recently
teased a potential new project a
tell-all book sometimes things aren't
better but sometimes but then they
always do get better that's the thing
that I find you know you just work
through it and then you get to a point
that's good
foreign